and that image is kind of you know the
jeans the t-shirt yeah working guy image
you have it's interesting that when you
were a kid what you loved were kind of
the showman like Elvis and agar and all
of that I regret it to this day I've
never I've never looked good dressed up
ridiculous when I get really dressed up
you know always wanted the gold the may
suit and but no they never worked for me
but you did practice like Jagger moves
and stuff too well every every frontman
worth his salt has stood in front of a
mirror at some point in time with these
as a broom or the tennis racquet and
spent hours just moving to little 45s in
his room so yeah that was a big part of
my my studies
[Music]
you